[Music]
our advance has taken a severe thrashing
but we must carry on we are to secure
this corridor and assault the German
airfield ahead capture each sector and
move on to the next Godspeed
[Music]
[Music]
supposed
[Music]
hey how's it going everybody Aaron
Sampson here and Ryan Schubert we're
gonna play some battlefield 5 today yeah
yeah we got the battlefield fives going
we're already in grant operations which
is a kind of rush like mode we actually
have not that we just fire the game up
so you're gonna watch us yeah this is
totally fresh like having played this
part having practice any of the
multiplayer just diving right in get on
that tow system
alright that's this basically early
review copy of the game and we're just
gonna dive right in but before we dive
right in announcement everybody should
know that GameSpot is going to be
live-streaming all weekend for charity
it's the Extra Life marathon it's about
72 hours long so show up hang out with
all your favorite games but people from
around the world United States
UK Australia everybody's gonna be in
there okay let's go let's get going
starting with getting in the vehicle
here yeah alright we are all right doing
all right team let's do this it's
capture point um I don't have anything
unlocked yet I noticed that I had some
veteran stuff which we can go to the
menu and take a look at after this and
see what what it gave us for being
veteran players also for those of you
who just want to get into the game
tomorrow you can actually throw a
grenade back to you sir um you can you
you can get in on battlefield 4
transplant engineer you can get on
backup for $15 actually if you just do
the origin early access or the super
origin subscriber or whatever they're
calling it these days and you can
actually play this game tomorrow for 15
bucks and then
hot tip if you don't like it you just
just you just not babe you've paid back
over 15 bucks if you do like it then
it's up to you keep going as I've
mentioned I actually this is the first
time we've played so you're gonna see me
kind of learning as we go
that's tank yeah that's not gonna work I
have all right handgun versus tank
rocket launchers private Ryan's so my
starting gears and all that useful
support classes starting with 80 minds
which hey you're gonna have to get real
close nope
there's a guy right here all right guy
right there um some of the new additions
are new he knows I'm here
where are you how's the rock the
attrition system which means you round
pama more often had an interesting
interview who's the lead multiplayer
producer who said they can actually
adjust the attrition system based on the
the map in the mode there's a man right
there huh smoke effect is actually
pretty good yeah all right all right all
right
not bad way to start I was gonna try and
shoot down an airplane I'm noting right
off the bat here the artillery camp
objective as an artillery weapon that's
a good thing Ryan why don't you talk
about useful objectives which is a kind
of criticism we've always had about yeah
I think one of our both of our sort of
bigger complaints of battlefield of
their last few installations oh yeah
thank you that objectives often have
almost no purpose they're just
almost an arbitrary point in space where
there's a flag to capture whereas a lot
of the older battlefield games had
objectives that actually had use for
your team where there would be vehicle
spawns artillery ammo just stuff like
that that make it actually worth
capturing not just hold the majority of
points in conquest so that you have a
lower ticket bleed although right now
their team seems to be holding the
majority points alright let's see if I
can see force I tank
cuz that's a fun thing to do happy to
say for sure though this looks fantastic
which is the force expected from
battlefield and the and the frostbite
engine
you don't worry about and I kind of you
know like a salt has all the goodies
this time around nope um well we'll see
we're like really early in the unlock
system but from the alpha beta it felt
like a salt had all of the good stuff
aged like a lot of it you traditionally
have given to the engineer class like
the anti-tank stuff I don't know we'll
see they're kind of anti inventory and
anti-tank which is a bit that's a lot
for like it feels like since I want to
say battlefield 3 that they started to
lean away from the significance of
having different classes and you can
also subspecialize this time around nope
the same guy um so you can have yourself
even more anti-tank which I guess there
isn't an engineer this time it's a
support guy uh we'll see what we're just
digging into it for the first time today
we did play alpha beta I did playthrough
war stories at a preview event and did
an interview with Dave saralyn's
who actually have any word on when the
review is going to come out what we had
we had people go to a review event
so we're not we're not gonna do the
review from the review event just
because it's a controlled environment we
don't necessarily like doing our reviews
from environments where the developers
get to choose what we what we see and
don't see and also we can't really we
don't know what the servers are gonna be
like in the wild right so we want to see
once it goes live how it actually
actually plays yeah let's try some
destruction hey can I crash my guy you
don't switch room oh yeah the old never
get on a mounted gun rule I don't even
have mount against a bow field anymore
it's a one-way ticket to a head shot
something else are gonna try and improve
on post-launch is i think even if i
unlock a scope this round I think I have
to quit out of a match to actually use
it
whoa get back doll that is actually
something that has been frustrating
about frostbite that it seems like they
have either never made an effort to fix
or are just simply unable to fix about
the engine that they can't do can't edit
loadouts either like in match or between
matches you have to fully quit out of
matchmaking to be able to do that stuff
my feet are on fire all right I probably
should figure out what I'm actually
supposed to be doing oh yeah that one
self heal thing so now every everybody
gets one self yield that was beta
feedback all right shake over see where
sugar Orion requests got some maps she
requests some maps what orders probably
new you should run out there and get
shot Aaron some people I swear to God in
this game some people are too good at
those long-range shots and then when you
try it you just spray everywhere and and
not hit things so while we're waiting
for Aaron to respawn
a quick question for the chat you know
what what if any is your favorite
battlefield game
kind of curious to know where people are
coming from you know I feel like I've
been playing battlefield for ever now a
lot of people a lot of people came in at
four hahaha
bad company - yes so they had to
challenge you know again I did an
interview with David Stirling who's the
lead multiplayer producer he was saying
that they he totally understands that
challenge oh I'm right back in the
turret I think can you duck again there
was an old battle games you could
totally die oh yeah I used to be able to
duck there no you're able to get out the
nice thing about the yes but the World
War 1 tanks were that they had those
side cannons so you could switch in
battlefield one to the side cannons
oh yeah and well actually all the
personnel vehicles in the modern games -
had like the machine guns on the sides
but ya know they fully recognized they
have a bunch of different audiences in
battlefield now depending on when you
came in if you were in bad company
versus battlefield 3 versus even the old
valve no two players let's see in the
chat we have some for some threesome
battlefield 2 people going back to the
battlefield - which was honestly I think
a lot of people felt like was in some
ways the height of battlefield when they
first yeah I mean I was when they unpin
see like the height of PC battlefield
but then bad company - we've got some
bad company - in here bad company - I
think really just fundamentally upgraded
the franchise in terms of like the
destruction was amazing the maps the
purpose-built maps we had purpose-built
maps that were made for rush made for
conquest Oh towing system might they
want to try it and then it's also sort
of impossible to forget the
the Vietnam expansion for Bad Company 2
as well I want to try the towing thing
I'm gonna mess around a bit
oh now that people already go weird that
two-vehicle give up tanks already in
fire just getting that thing and they
have so I think those vehicles are
supposed to show these vehicles um I'm
really curious what players will do
later on when they start to to mess with
that system more that looks like a pre
destroyed vehicle we're gonna take a
hike that's another thing that I've had
sort of a gripe with since Bad Company 2
3 after Bad Company 2 like from
battlefield 3 on was they knew they had
a good thing with destruction in Bad
Company 2 and then they just walked it
back and walked it back and now you have
these maps where you have pre destroyed
terrain you have like it's like a battle
has already been fought here and you
don't get to do it and the greatest
thing about Bad Company 2 is that every
map started pristine and it took all of
the players to completely destroy it
it's cool weed you know we destroyed it
for you can I do the old switcheroo
on the medic you take their genetic kit
and then you revive them I got to try
that that's an all about battlefield
classic right yeah take out in the salt
take their kid let's try the yellow
switch back the old kits which room see
if we can do it can I switch room I can
Bob Jones is asking what was the heist
battlefield game that was hard time
buddy revive you know I liked hardline
more than I'm willing to admit you know
I think that tried line tried something
new
hardline tried to change it up a little
bit we had you know a different theme
that really didn't fit the franchise and
it if you were you know maybe into
there's a cops and robbers type thing
you probably thought you know payday 2
was better but I got to say that I think
they they tried and they did okay well
and you know a certain amount of credit
is due as well to you know as much as
hardline might not have been a popular
as a core battlefield game this role did
a lot of work on improving the engine
they did a lot of interesting work to on
so they fixed the sound through floor
bugs they added in unique melee weapons
if you don't remember they're the ones
that made it so that you could shoot
down helicopters with with just regular
weapons so like players could just focus
fire on air assets and they weren't as
helpless as they were before which I
thought was really cool come on acute
there's got to be
I really I can't duck it's like a thing
in battlefield it all right switch seats
no that's some old battlefield
yeah like cuz otherwise I don't know
turrets are always dead hundred percent
just always death guarantee death oh I
can't believe actually hit somebody
but yeah just to give it a little bit
more I don't know
I think fair lip service for a lot of
things that were janky and didn't make
any sense about hardline I thought it
was kind of cool to take the battlefield
style game play into a different
environment there were a few maps in
that game that were legitimately fun to
play so wonder if he can jump though
conceptually it made no sense sorry just
real quick I wonder if he can jump off
this bridge so one things they mentioned
was wanting to have a map that repeated
something like game and he yeah although
Damavand peak had a purpose it did its
purpose was fun there you go
actually getting on a 50 Cal has always
been one of my favorite things to do in
a battlefield game yeah for as long as
it lasts I'm riding this I'm riding this
beast into the ground oh you know what
I'm gonna try and jump off
nope time to go oh that's interesting he
goes out through the back okay oh wow
what was that tank panzerschreck
actually that's just the Panzer
straight-up Panzer they're doing some
interesting stuff with a story after
this week - I think what in two weeks
they're doing the German storyline the
last tiger obviously they'll have to
handle the subject matter delicately but
I'm more excited about the idea of large
tank battles kind of like they in our
desert band our desert is great man I'm
not gonna recon but this feels like such
a recon moment yeah maybe you got it
maybe you got to do some sniping so can
we actually see the map for a second
yeah kind of trying to get a lay of the
land
like we're so this is grand operations
it's more of a straight shot OOP yeah
are we doing this we're gonna do it
suicide mission cross bridge this is
gonna go great
I can tell
nope you know he does not agree come on
oh you don't I bet there's a lower round
there's a tank stop all right
yeah I mean like battlefields at its
best when you can just do dumb things so
let's let's find the lower route got it
unlock the cheap stuff why is there okay
okay
hey Oh God Oh some things never change
in frostbite alright alright let's do
this yeah now you're now you're with me
now weird nope now you're not with me
just does not like where this is going
this is a pretty big man oh god it's try
as you might to turn that over Aaron
that is the you know in battlefield
hardline that's what I was just called a
hand of God it just like tries to right
your vehicle like you're a toy every
time good luck trying to flip a vehicle
I wonder if you have any like spawn you
know like the was it the lav from
battlefield 3 the Amtrak Amtrak you're
right the Amtrak yeah alright come on
guys come on I you know spawn on me you
know what you gotta do driving the
Amtrak used to be one of my favorite
things cuz I'd love just trying to find
like a weird place to hide that thing
you're an objective where it would take
the other team like minutes to figure
out that climbing our team was spawning
all over them it's not gonna go well
solo but we will explore for exploration
I'm not gonna hold F by myself Oh teams
do any all right let's let's go help out
with if we can without getting shot
thinks it's weird that we got it early
this is review copy and it is also
retail so this is the full version of
the game we've got it here to stream
for you one advantage of abena video
game journalism outlet oh I can say wow
just just sort of sneak your but--can oh
I thought I wasn't really get up on that
thing
level 2 assaults alright can I have moat
yep yep cool I'm anchoring I like
anchoring it's actually one of my
favorite things to do
she's like gonna stand out there that
way alright alright wait you got cheap
stuff idea of jeeps now spread it around
the objective and you can Jeep stuff
this time actually I have stuck it to
vehicles in the past it worked all right
we're in a fortress this is going better
than I expected it's a nice mosaic
doesn't look like they're doing any of
the photo
gyum am a tree that's the way you
pronounce it right I'm pretty sure that
is exactly how you pronounce so I should
just go to G like what's what's what you
doing oh okay there they back fighting
for D and B but this is grand operation
so are we just supposed to be moving
forward is there like a locking mechanic
right so what separates grand operations
from conquest is what I can tell so far
is a straight line I thought so the
great operations on what the Narvik map
you actually took a series of ejected
but then they were kind of permanently
taken and this okay I hear definitely
here the other guys so I'm trying to
classic battlefield flanking maneuver
hmm and I don't know what happens yet
cuz this is the first time we fired this
game up Oh
[Music]
so wonder if we can just take her your
objective
so bleeding out is or you just get the
revive this is people thought it took me
along in the end the beta so apparently
my team is going back to take a rear
point how you doing good I just spun on
you how about you let's do this
nope this is the danger lockout which is
actually kind of nice yeah it took a
little while for them to come around on
having the dangerous fun lockout but I
think we all battlefield players agree
that was an upgrade yeah I mean it was
it's it's nice to not immediately get
shot in the back when you spawn or just
okay alright alright we're doing this I
totally forgot about this we're gonna
build things let's do this
nice battlefield threat I don't know why
you would ever build a stationary turret
though because it's a hundred percent
death all the time let's build this
build this puppy in the open nope
Kanchana
honestly though I think this is kind of
a cool feature this is something that I
think is definitely me a pretty cool
addition to Battlefield is being able to
sort of build up your fortifications I'm
kind of a I don't know I've been playing
a lot of for tonight over the past
couple seasons whoa
kind of in the mindset if you're gonna
let people build just let them build
don't limit where the building happens
whoa nice I like that worked out have
they towed up a six pounder so again
we're just kind of learning the map
right now that was cool though it looks
like that the other team actually turned
up again in the chat Fredrik is saying
no this is not for me they better leave
this world war one or two Herrera and
get real we want modern weapons to fight
with so my pitch for the next
Battlefield game is over love got my
pitch for the next battlefield game if I
just could make it whatever I wanted
would be Special Forces across the ages
I would love to have a Special Forces
battlefield game that kind of like how
bad coming to you did it they went
through a couple different eras and also
modern it's kind of hard to beat
helicopters I will always miss I'll
always miss helicopters they're just
such a fun part of battlefield in any
error that does not have helicopters is
just not as cool
not as cool errantly my other pitch is
um I bet you can destroy that now we
also did
about World War three the game if you're
looking for a modern shooter the World
War three might be what you're looking
for it's very very similar to
battlefield 3 battlefield 4 a little bit
it's still early acts oh there's still a
lot of work to be done on it but it does
scratch that itch pretty well I think
yeah I mean if you're just looking for
the modern the modern battlefield 4
style game world war 3 does have it oh
that sounds like a BTU coming in we had
somebody calling me calling for bad
company 3 in the chat yeah they should
just make back Heaven III it does seem
strange to me that they have completely
avoided bad company 3 it feels like if
this game were just pitches back Kevin
III a lot of the silliness over
customization would've gone away because
bad company is just silly by nature
didn't get that squad spawn in time
maybe I should just this guy's doing so
good I maybe should switch to medic and
help him out all right let's try this
I really have anything unlock yet the
tickets are almost out get in there
quick
it's gonna get some revives on nope
they're gonna shot in the back twelve
nine
8:05 you know it's not going well
all right team
it's a just do some one we got one deke
one figure should we have the honor
being the last to die
capture it stop the bleed okay you got a
grenade now as long as you nobody gets
killed yeah we're good you're good
nobody died and we're good
nope who died nope somebody died I blame
whoever died zero to 20 so close I do
apologize I'm in a segment some
shadowplay capture because we may use
some of this for our review so you might
see me stop and start some [ __ ] and play
what questions do you guys have so far
what outfit would you guys like to see
next and I like are you interested in
this in this battlefield and their
roadmap coming up they're gonna do in
the next three months rush I'd thought
grand operations was gonna be held but
it seems like it's out okay they're
gonna do tank battles within a couple
weeks and they're still working on
firestorm which I'm not opposed like
firestorm seems like battlefield if
anything Bethel's probably where the
better matches for Battle Royale
to be honest they've always done
large-scale they're sort of sort of back
in battlefield 3 sort of it wasn't
single spawn but yeah an aftermath
expansion there was scavenger where you
started with I think a knife and did you
I think you had a pistol maybe somebody
in check and remember and you picked up
guns that just had different amounts of
bullets in them which I thought always
really cool battle royale mode is not
gonna be out until spring so you can get
in for those who are just joining us now
you can actually get in tomorrow and
battlefield 5 for 15 bucks with origins
super fast thing and then if you like it
keep paying and if you don't like it
cancel after month and you've played
back they'll apply for 15 bucks but
they're gonna you know battlefield 5 has
a has a pretty long roadmap going at
least through spring weather can compete
with you know games like anthem coming
out division will see like it's cool
they're not gonna segment their their
audience you'll you know
when you pay once and then you'll be
able to play on servers and any servers
through all the rest of the content
that's the idea as opposed to past
battlefields where if you didn't have
the DLC you couldn't even get into the
server queue for a lot of lot of servers
later on ok now I'm remembering so grand
operations has phases that phase was
like the conquest phase was the conquest
phase of green operations and I think
now we're in more of a rush phase ok my
day is saying I miss rush mode i 100%
agree
I miss rush mode - Russia is coming it's
one of the things coming in the first
three months I'll believe it when I see
ok let's open up some new routes I'm
gonna try this but that's for Jeeps
yes all right we got routes that are
actually opening up unlike a battlefield
hardline net remember like the only way
to open up was - that's ok we still have
scope when remember the only way to open
up like vaults and down field hardline
was man my team is really dying on this
oh yeah you couldn't use any actual like
c4 open vaults you actually had to do a
quick time event yeah quick time event
basically gluten which is so not
battlefield
man I got a I gotta learn how to feather
again you know I'm impressed with this
Alleppey this team's used to smoke is
good the right now these other teams are
properly using smoke crime is asking do
they have custom games or can you run a
server I'm assuming that it would be
down the road if it's not usually
available at lunch usually ran a server
comes later all right so did we
so now we have to go okay we're holding
it we probably put hold what a and B I
gotta get a good feel for these guns
nope that's gonna have a snack have an
ammo snack I don't know I think we just
have to hold this and then say I want a
Mighty Mouse smoke cuz that'd be awesome
how my question is always like how did
they kill me from that range and then I
try and do it and it doesn't work
a cell pill all right oh I got one of
those too buddy
we both have one of those all right
they're smoking I'm going up and right
oh that was a ammo station
nope that's a house a sniper with a big
flashlight this is where previously I
would have loved to have had a mortar
all right team we're doing good feel
good push it up
Sheila on this uh I really no I really
don't I still don't like the scope Flint
it doesn't it kind of like is the exact
opposite of what a sniper rifle should
be and I feel like they solved that
problem a long time ago just with trace
right back in bad company - you could
just you just had sort of a bullet trail
you could see and that that gave them
the first shot which is what a recon
player supposed to have if you were
looking in the right direction you would
notice it and that was kind of enough to
hunt down a sniper but you know if they
went for too long and overstayed their
welcome then you would figure out
exactly where they were which i think is
perfect okay good job team good job
let's do this cross open ground nope
nope that's kind of forgot the slide
slide so easy on controllers god I want
to snipe that man so bad with a rocket
but I don't have one right now nope huh
I actually died to one of these earlier
really yeah nice that's pretty cool all
right all right did I get my rocket back
cuz I really want to kill the sniper
there we go yeah I'm a rocket man
no there's another guy who needs to die
time for you to die buddy where is it oh
good
worth it we streamed battlefield 1 the
other day and I was most deadly with
Rockets against horses that was my
specialty
Travis Graham is asking for war stories
we can definitely if you guys want to
see it well I'm happy to hop out and do
a war story and now you've played some
of war stories already yeah they're good
they're good little snippets of the war
I like I like how you're not stuck in a
one-person story and it's a chance to
tell a lot of interesting stories you
know obviously I don't really come to
battlefield for single-player I've
always kind of felt that I don't know my
question has always been what is that
what are you giving up for single-player
like it you know in that regard I kind
of respect Call of Duty for just not
doing single-player this year because
how many more Maps does that buy you you
know how many more Mo's does that buy
you right but on the other hand I really
agree with that actually you know I'm
that's just my opinion and I know a lot
of people play these games for the
campaign's in which case from what I've
played you probably won't be
disappointed I got to say the skis were
so much fun and it was weird but one of
the one of the missions had skis and it
was my standout favorite new addition to
this game so much so that I hope they
add it to multiplayer man this feels
like that hill in a bad company
this is a very tough advance yeah
it's interesting you see those guys
getting pings
you can see it just getting destroyed
that's cool house is getting destroyed
man
could really use some more ammo yeah
listen this is deep stuff
deep stuff do it
looks like the house is getting
destroyed which is cool all right
Oh still you got a good kill out of it
kind of want to see what happens when we
start getting scopes in the mix caught
puts very little effort into their modes
though like Dave they were the pioneers
of gun game
I think Kill Confirmed was at least
something over team deathmatch I like I
don't know I very much like Call of Duty
this year quite a lot particularly with
the hero operator focus can i okay so
you're not on the squad so I can't
revive you they've made changes to some
of this stuff nice all right I got a
little tank advance going getting killed
by the crossfire let's go team oh we got
to take B and B's in the middle nope
nope
he's just right there in that rock
it's definitely feels like one of those
meat grinder kind of areas where you'd a
bit of a bottleneck your whole team has
to push at the exact same time you're
just not going anywhere
oh they're up on the hill now Oh No
the temptation is snipe here is real
give it a shot
how are your sniping skills a little
rusty but might be worth it
although my rocket sniping skills better
they're kind of coming around on a flank
right now there's an up there's an area
up there oh 9 T 7 my team is pushing
right interesting ok we still haven't
taken B so we got a whole day and be
honest fired my rockets and there's a
tank so that's my was that a squad order
that's a
what I can try recon I'm curious because
recon now has the spotting scale
we're only playing grant operations
right now the other thing you have fatal
injury the other thing we can hop into
is conquest so we can take a look at
explore some of the maps kind of that
will think we're indeed three right now
focus on so super mandible claw says
this looks as boring as bf1 do you do
you feel like this so far differentiates
itself from from battlefield one or is
it just sort of more of the same
yeah I'm curious so like I think
people's definition of boring is
different depending on what you're
looking for huh
good job medic where am I um I think
typically when battlefield when
battlefield 2 players come in what they
consider boring is too much
infantry focus as opposed to more of a
slower tactical move around the map
right maybe after this will pop out and
try and find a conquest server just to
begin to explore it how do I get out
deploy overview so I want to switch
class we don't have any unlocks yet
there even if the team is really not
making a push on B I mean the other
thing that you and I have always found
with battlefield games ok I got mine
spotting scope is a if you're on a
losing team oftentimes it's just not
gonna change
there's definitely some clearly dominant
teams
alright let's put a mine here nope nope
and nope how is he still hitting me nope
nope
and yeah that didn't go well let's see
vsips on my mind though I put a mine
right over my body step on it it's right
there it's right there come on step out
oh man okay okay thank know they're
starting to push for be alright I like
tanks let's try it how do I sneakily
have one gun nope got two guns we got
repair extreme 1505 says if you don't
like it don't buy it yeah I think that's
a general rule of all video games I mean
actually I think that's just a generally
in capitalism if you don't like it don't
buy it that is that is the best vote
that you have with trade a says any sign
of the whimsical vibe from the trailers
or was that aspect completely scrapped
customization it's likely still there
but we can go take a look for you
actually not something I really wanted
to do it's a good question though
because those like that first trailer in
particular was just bananas they have
said that they've toned it down pear
tree burgers so I'm gonna have to back
out if I want to look at customization
which is something that so this is still
a grand operation correct yeah weather
is kind of cool though this is sort of
what I thought kind of dragged down the
fun for me in battlefield one was that
in this attempt to sort of try to
replicate rush they just were stringing
individual matches together
and that got to me that got pretty
boring especially like having to wait
between matches like back in the day
playing rush you took your objectives
and you kept the momentum going
and here it's like if you have momentum
it just totally dies for 45 seconds or a
minute while you're waiting for the next
match after absolute after you today
essentially yeah yeah well I mean we are
gonna get rush within I think the first
wave the first or second wave of Yosi so
maybe I'll play this for a little bit in
them will pop out because I want to take
a look at some weapon customization want
to look at conquest and we had some
requests to do war uh war stories yeah
war stories has a has a prologue that
kind of I can get into which is an
overview of the entire campaign
essentially so you get it you get a
sampler that man has a British logo on
it again no artillery alright
does that mean I can fire it I can't
fire it did where did it go is there
gonna be like a splash okay maybe recon
calls the ball on that one
oh okay they're coming in you're
supposed to shoot there pear tubers
alright hi team hey it's almost sin
crossing they David sterling said that
they were heavily inspired by and that's
their brave troopers heavily inspired by
some of your favorite maps from
battlefield 3 and battlefield 4 so I
think you'll okay it's cool I like how
my team's fortifying here see you
probably will see
[Music]
oh we should have blown that Ridge you
can do that you're probably you'll
probably see things that you that you
recognize it at least the flavor of what
is the artillery it says I can fire it
but what what am I didn't seem like I
was aiming it I was just into to music
one says the sound quality and bf games
is so good I played black ops and I
don't like the gun sounds every gun
sounds the same to me I you know that is
something true and has always been true
for Battlefield is the sound has been
such a crucial part of the game and that
is something I think that you know
despite some of our criticism of
Battlefield over the years I don't think
you and I have ever felt that the sound
wasn't top-notch the sound has just been
excellent from start to finish through
the entire series and frostbite is so
good at sound
do I not oh I don't even think I have my
syringe yet although shout out on the
side to insurgency yeah if there's a
game that's done incredible sound design
lately it's yours if you're looking for
a shooter on PC that does sound
insurgency is amazing insurgency also
just some things that I would love
battlefield to do actually don't work so
we were supposed to have a co-op
campaign at launch which we're not gonna
have their bandages okay make bandages
but
co-op in addition to single-player and
multiplayer I think is like everything
tying into one system I hope you down
everybody's down everything tying into
one central progression system in my
opinion is the best what what I think
that holy moly says who wants bad
company to remastered you know I'd take
that at this point like I would take bad
company to just take everything all the
same Maps and just update them for
current gen consoles and more powerful
pcs mature and blow the bridge I would
totally take a remastered that company
too
I have kind of wondered why in have bad
company 3 I would take that time Kenichi
remastered in a heartbeat
I kind of wonder sometimes why they hate
money I think a lot of people would play
ok let's try this
I think a lot of people would play a
compilation nope I thought that was the
thing you could do was that wrong
could you not do that I swear that was a
thing you could do yes I did it all
right now our tank can't cross that was
worth it I'm glad they brought that back
though like it's been a long time since
leveling a bridge was an even viable
strategy in a battlefield game it used
to be you could do it everywhere yeah I
remember so many matches on variations
of Wake Island where the almost the
first thing people would do is destroy
the bridges
and make it a pain for the armor to move
around or Jeeps
all right let's get in this and figure
out what's going on what's going on is
grenades from that side of the map the
People's Champ says world war two hahaha
so boring I don't know I kind of felt
like I wanted what World War two again a
couple of years ago I don't know if I
still feel the same way but battlefield
hasn't done World War two in a very long
time not since a lot of this stuff you
know
frostbite got better and I was
definitely down two to go that way but
that said if you weren't here earlier
we're talking about World War three it's
a new game in early access it's
definitely not a triple-a title but it
looks good sound needs a lot of work but
it is very much in the spirit of
battlefield 4 and
battlefield 3 I'm gonna flip over to a
flu shot in the back and on the on fire
gonna get a lot of problems there all
right let's do the back prune and see if
we get shot the foot
Oh oh no no no no we both have grenades
Hey Oh that did not end well
grenade spam less of a problem this time
around but still maybe black ops I'd
look again I'm gonna keep saying how
much I really like black ops this year
they've done a great job of just vastly
reducing grenade spam which is so
essential and just making everything
feel fair and skill based as opposed to
just whoever lost the most grenades add
an objective well only one I think only
one of the characters and black ops has
a throwable explosive and then you can
still equip a frag grenade if you to be
fair yeah and you unlock it if you get
rid of your primary ability
that's it feels like a little bit a
little bit of a cop-out I prefer they
didn't even go that far to be fair
though to be completely fair the
cooldown on that as as long as it is for
everything else so it's not that big a
deal
they're just gonna
honestly in a nutshell what I don't like
in battlefield is these funnels just get
no old like when everybody just gets
caught up in these funnels I like the
funnel more than then the just wide open
fishbowl I'll say that it's like um it's
sort of what how I fell off on
battlefield one was there was like the
maps weren't so big that you weren't
constantly running in circles
um so here's the thing the respawns need
to be far enough back that an advancing
team can actually make progress and when
those spaces are just immediately filled
with players running in as you're
clearing them out that creates a
situation where you never feel like
you're making any progress and then the
match doesn't really flow seems like a
few people might be a little confused
about something I said a few minutes ago
I did not say that battlefield 5 is not
triple-a I said that world war 3 is not
triplet that's true world war 3 is
definitely early access but if you
wanted that modern warfare type of
experience not battle not Call of Duty
but like modern combat then you might
want to check out world war 3 on TC it's
only a 28 bucks on Steam actually I I I
highly recommend it it's not it's not as
polished as battlefield sound design is
not that great but the shooting aspects
of it are great the weapon customization
is great the way that they handle
objectives I enjoy quite a lot can I
build oh I can't build you know really
does have that feel
like battlefield 3 and 4 yeah I mean if
you want modern it gives you modern I
think if you go out there and fortify
you're just gonna get shot
looking forward if I hear that excu this
nope not not here see you again these
attrition systems in these fortification
systems I feel like they're built for
large Maps and they just don't really
work on small maps cuz there's just not
enough time to do them I was given a
injury plus this is a this is a map that
people have seen so I'm curious I really
want to see the large bridge map that
was in that original yeah trailer you
it's on here it's at launch and we
definitely have to do war stories but I
would like to try and see one more
multiplayer map before we're done with
the stream Johnny Royalle says PT fo
dude from with PT fo it's just so much
getting shot on the back that's the
biggest things with battlefield is just
the amount of time people end up behind
you dead and it used to be a problem and
I feel like in a grand operations style
map the funnel the funnel should be like
good enough that if you're gonna do a
like a progress based objective yeah
there's no way I'm going up there if
you're gonna do a progress based map you
need you need like bad company got it
was like a mixtape right so like the
first objective was a little bit easy
for the team and to take attacking team
Jase then the second objective or the
third objective was the really hard one
and it would end with another easier
hard one it was he was like the mixtape
approach right and that gave people a
really good sense of like at least I got
somewhere and often like terrain changes
and sort of like this scenario itself
changed over time like you might start
off the the rush map with taking a beach
but you might find yourself partway
through like fighting in an urban
environment and then on a hillside after
that yeah and they also they did a good
job of using the terrain to make things
harder or easier so you know like having
to fight uphill is harder having to
fight people and cover a cross up and
ground is harder it was more than just
you know like giving one team a tank or
something like that to back out of this
way let's back out and try conquests
just full-on quit let's just full-on
should we check out some of the let me
know my news yeah let me flip through
some of the menus and show you guys I'll
tell you what why don't we do some menus
then we'll do the prologue because the
prologue is just a good sample of every
you know that sounds good and then we'll
go into like a larger conquest map my
day is taken off to play Bad Company 2
on Steam nice you do that heck yeah
go sick leave a bad company to twisted
steel just one great game okay so let's
flip through some menus okay so your
company here's our soldier customization
see what we got in there let's dig in
oh you know what actually I had some
veteran benefits that I think we need to
do first see assignments
armory here we go six veteran rewards
it's always been the 1911 the 1911
we got the SAS operative it was a
battlefield for try think three or four
four I think in battlefield for the 1911
was my top weapon if I went and looked
at my stats online it was I had the 1911
was my my top weapon and then my like
third or fourth top weapon was the
separately separately available
suppressed 1911 like the Special Forces
one with the flashlight I think we ended
up calling it the Han Solo again so I
was just 1911 crazy back then Wow
you have to accept these one at a time
menus never never Bend I stood strong
suit nope nope confirm and then this
should hopefully unlock some stuff for
us to mess with the weapons so we can
show you guys real quick al our driver
if you are just joining us here on our
battlefield 5 preview livestream we have
a review copy of the game it's review
time for Battlefield 5 and we are
allowed to stream it right now so we
thought we'd share it with everybody
else all right your company let's
customize also GameSpot is having a 72
hour charity livestream all this weekend
all territories US UK Australia
everybody's live-streaming just about
everybody on staff I think is going to
appear on the livestream and it's gonna
be awesome
that's quite a scope alright let's let's
toss that skip on nope that's not I do
it get that get that authentic yep you
got a click in nineteen forties optic
red dot scope okay this is got the
muzzle colored let's quit that lets but
yes this is a
is a review copy this is like the full
retail version of the game standard
receiver what's a lot of sub menus I'm
not gonna lie okay Equipe Quebec and so
you can color each part of the gun well
this is this is pretty granular alright
this is a thing every every little part
it's it's it's like Red Dead Redemption
at that point specialization so this is
their system that you were previously
locked into I think you're still locked
into it so you have to think purchase a
new weapon if you want to go down
another path so this gun has quickcam
[Music]
custom stock and then what's this quick
reload enhance grips light and stock
okay so you can kind of tweak guns how
you like it
shake click replace weapon what happens
when you click that's you what happens
that makes me nervous you get stuck with
it there's a lot of menus here to
customize I'm gonna click it ah
before you click it and we find out that
you get luck they just deleted something
I have to say though doesn't anything
have to be better than the weapon unlock
system in battlefield 1 weapon unlocks
not that not the strongest suit
ok oh cool all right here's a got a
helmet and the illusionists
do like a decent jacket I don't know
yeah all right
paladin look at me like that paladin
okay let's go with you got a better hat
though you don't want the kind of like
that hat what are the other options and
then face paint ooh
I don't think of anything unlocked here
oh we can probably see if it gets too
silly it seems like they've toned it
it's definitely not very silly yeah it
seems like they've definitely toned it
down I don't have any of these but if
they bring in if they bring back the
silly stuff it seems like it's gonna be
later on hero says those reflux lights
bother this [ __ ] out of me we actually
looked it up so they were invented I
agree though after the war I believe I
think they were like kind of
conceptualize during the war I don't I
that just I know that a lot of
developers will say that fun wins but
that's something that really bothered me
with battlefield 1 like there are so
many weapons in that game where the the
explanation was well there was a
prototype at that time it's like yeah
well there weren't like 20 people on the
battlefield carrying that prototype
though yeah I mean world war 1 did not
have tons of automatic weapons ok let me
get you guys into a war story real quick
hopefully we'll just play through the
prologue oh sorry tides of war was the
thing that was coming Oh grand
operations is there I was incorrect
earlier and then practice range is
coming December 4th mmm they're bringing
that back at least let me do the
introduction because it's a it's like a
good sampler of everything oh that's
right you can kind of play these in
whatever order you want the last tiger I
think this one's coming in two weeks
oK we've already played through all
these and posted some of it let's do a
we're gonna do the prologue just because
it has has a sampler of the war stories
it sounds good
thorns a an Americans Russians Pacific
Theater plans coming through tides of
war
[Music]
I mean if the full like roadmap that
they're talking about like what they
laid out when they first presented this
game is legit that they're gonna
basically do all of World War two
there's that is kind of cool like the
ultimate world war two multiplayer game
the original content proposed will all
be there by but I believe March if you
want to play right now that you can play
for fifteen bucks you just sign up for
the origin pass and if you don't want to
pay the month after that that's up to
you I go Blitzer wants us to play the
damn game so we've been doing buddy been
playing for about an hour and we had
some folks asking about customization
wanting to see some of the menus so
we're showing them that stuff and we're
getting right back to the gameplay
this country is at war
my father asked me if I was truly ready
to go to war
he told me that the good soldier kills
without thinking of his enemy as a human
being in the moment he sees him as a
fellow man he's no longer a good soldier
and I was a good soldier god help me
what's a chat we're playing a prologue
right now I'm defying greatness
of our future that future must be chosen
[Music]
it must be driven with conviction
Wester our lesson a chance that it's
Trey
it was that John McCain gentleman John
McCain was Vietnam battlefield does
still have a story mode if you're
looking for it it's a looks like four
chapters
well prologue plus three chapters plus
the German kid like short story coming
I'd believe it it's about two weeks I
believe we have a question what video
card are we're using it I believe we
have a 1080 in this battlefield always
looks good custom people seem to be
enjoying it all right
so this is a war stories this is the
prologue prologue just kind of takes you
through um a sampler of all of the war
stories
I do till they died in my grenade huh
you like that heat effect just stop with
my bullets I do you feel like I'm
getting caught on a lot of environmental
objects the old ankle snag problem so
much snow over my face
now given what they're able to do with
frostbite in single-player I totally get
why they do single blur and to be fair
loads all does show off the engine it
makes good trailers the most egregious
example of it just being used for the
trailer was the airplane scene from
battlefield raids cats where you didn't
actually fly the airplane
oh right yeah
we disagree widely on that mission hey I
actually like the copilot mission in
Battlefield 3's one of those and if I'm
honest it's maybe the only mission I
really like out of the battlefield
single-player but then I I've mostly
skipped single-player since then from
honest I've never been a big
single-player fan in these games
although I do think that Call of Duty
had a few good single-player story
campaigns Call of Duty's usually good at
single-player it's kind of what they're
good at modern warfare modern warfare 2
and I thought was the advanced warfare I
thought that one is actually pretty good
too
they had a like a very Battlestar
Galactica style story that was cool it
had seamless transitions between
fighting in spacecraft and ground oh
that was cool see a turret pop up
I really am looking forward to the the
larger tank battle DLC that's not even
DLC anymore it's just I guess content
release schedule
I think battlefield thrives on larger
Maps to me it's like the larger the Mac
kind of the better to talk the greatest
killing machine is Man 4 people are
talking about price I would like to
point out you can actually play this
tomorrow for $15 it's the origin access
pass
and you could probably you know if
you're not sure about it you could
probably get what you want out of it for
15 bucks and then just not subscribe the
following month and you would you would
have played battle go for $15 or if you
liked it I keep going there are sections
of a single-player campaign - that just
completely open up which are which is
really cool it's just an environment you
can run around in you see me dead so
right now we're playing the prologue
which is not cheap in the story it's
just kind of a sample of the stories
hunter o'clair says I love infinite
warfare Ecostar agreed honestly when
they announced that there was not going
to be campaign and the new Call of Duty
that's immediately what I thought it was
infinite warfare
wow you aren't this time okay it wasn't
just about good I don't know multiplayer
shooters Oh God air controls I mean you
know me I I am a I'm a proponent of
multiplayer games that are multi player
right now because that's normally what I
want out of a multiplayer game you know
I'm not that interested in the story and
I think it's okay for those games to
co-exist but it's kind of frustrating
that both have to sacrifice for each
other you know we can't just have a
really good multiplayer game and a
really good single-player game it's like
there's a they sort of have to clash
with each other we only have so much
budget exactly and I just kind of wish
sometimes they were different things
like I think of battlefield branded
single-player franchise would be totally
fine they could if they want to
annualize the game maybe do it that way
I have a single-player every other year
and have multiplayer every other year
and make sure that you support both of
them for long enough you could
definitely play a battlefield
multiplayer game for two years with a
good deal
see schedule I've got air controls you
know you get new maps every few months
some new weapons like they could do that
they really should have taken criterions
air controls from battlefront
because they were so good Star Wars yeah
mouse mouse controls are just so not
good
particularly controls I think that's
where actually you have a big advantage
if you play on console and flying flying
is just way better where you can hook up
that old joystick there the recycling
the battlefield music just saying hey
let's do an air game somehow
it's telling me to shoot people who are
really far away am I supposed to shoot
these guys David Schulenburg saying
using WASD + arrow keys is easier than
Mouse maybe you got it you guys switch
up your your fly style criterion did it
though and so good I legitimately cannot
tell who does you shoot all the planes
to shoot them all down so I think that's
a friendly nice shoot back at me
I gotta invert nope I got invert and
infantry volunteers conscripts that's ok
the story moves on came from
Thanks this I can do that or you know
who's gonna be in the day now we've got
an eye Megan all right there's the
bridge you wanted to see it multiplayer
yeah see how it goes
it's there checking you out
nice outfit
that's a cool effect
probably gonna tell me to do this
again this is actually just a prologue
so there's a kind of a sampler of war
stories as opposed to anything too deep
at this point
good a lot of the war stories do give
you open areas to roam which is actually
pretty cool this is just a more
contained introduction to the game oh so
more open areas is in like a little bit
in the bad company direction it's
actually a lot yeah some of the areas
are just completely open you just can do
the objectives however you want
you're meant to die your way through
this intro no katanas yeah no my mic is
honest
okay
worthy is creation what Lenny back to us
shake it off
both in the same violence blood hunter
o'clair is asking hey GameSpot do you
knows to chunka join Lord to chunka yeah
we don't make fun of the Lord here at
GameSpot actually I did one time one
time one time you made the mistake of
making fun of Lord to Champa yep
I think I called him one of the worst
worst characters in siege and uh boy was
there hell to pay for that I love
picking tachanka though just to troll a
little bit it's the troll a bit if your
if your team is up you know just like
picking like all recruits it's like
sometimes it's just fun to roll to
chunky
I don't watch a lot of proceeds but I
remember watching one match where they
just somebody picked a chunk ax and just
used the chunka to level out all of the
walls on the mat first and then just get
didn't get off the machine gun just like
right before the game started sometimes
finding Vic 546 is asking how many of
those open environments are in
multiplayer friends the one that I
played did not cross over in a
multiplayer crime is saying wow skip
other people's legit questions to just
read about to chunka how do you
disrespect the Lord
come on crime
maybe it's a shockable I get his mojo
someday
[Music]
hey they they change that game all the
time is this game historically accurate
maybe in spirit the the war stories are
actually based on actual research that
they did but do not expect multiplayer
to be historically accurate because you
die more than once if if it was
historically accurate you would get one
life you would viewed by battlefield you
would get one life and then the game
would uninstall itself when you die the
first time let's see it's quarter after
do we want to do a little bit more
multiplayer yeah I would like to hop in
a conquest because we haven't taken a
look at that yet alright I was just
giving you giving you a little [ __ ]
crime what what questions actually have
we been missing so honestly like I think
if you're looking for historical
accuracy the war stories is where that's
at otherwise video games they tend to
focus on the fun okay I'm really worried
about just clicking in you a random
conquest because battlefield has a
history if is there any server browser
there is they were kind of full alright
let's like um there's a history of it
throwing a match by herself
multiplayer conquests yeah I'm with
crime here we definitely want to see new
maps yeah I would like to anyway to
server browse I think that's probably
the best way to do it um you can serve
her browse okay so you can server browse
it looks like I can't do it here but I
can do it for granted again it was when
I hit play one second
I remember it it was there I swear was
there
multiplayer advanced search here we go
grand operations on this map we haven't
seen this map yet but a kana want to see
conquest you guys want see grand
apparitions I think these are all this
whole deals the one you wanted we
haven't seen this one yet so let's just
hit it with let's just hit this one
are on twisted steel right now should we
give chat a moment to catch up if they
have a preference
I think twisted Steel's maybe we haven't
seen posted we haven't seen twisted
steel yet so let's hop on this although
we are still in grant operations please
stick to multiplayer happily that's
that's what we like I would like to get
into conquests either on the stream a
little bit later today though and just
kind of see what the free forum is like
on these maps it looked like these only
have four maps and rotation per mode
though which is that is whirring that's
the battlefront approach the thing where
I remember when they before battlefront
launched they said oh we've got eight
mode all these maps and then when he
went to play it was like each mode had
format it's kind of what you've talked
about with siege where you can play an
entire night without ever seeing turn
maps easily that's what I love about
siege you know especially if you're
playing ranked you know those matches
can take 45 minutes and you know if you
only play a few then you don't really
get bored of the maps
yeah whereas if this has four it's
possible I'll go back to the server
browser but it it honestly looked like
it only had four maps per mode and there
were only two modes right now at launch
so that's suspicious you'll see we will
see
if I'm being honest I think this game
still the bridge played him up we're
right here
yeah only 16 bring the Thunder
fortifications troy'd can I destroy the
trees that are there to strategically
block my view of the objective we've got
a couple people in chat general beauty
21 and rue de Juan Mart both asking for
sniping you might have to try it here
you might have to get ahead of it take
one for the team big one for the team I
will I'm I'm I'm more of a tanker
engineer but I I will happily show you
sniping if you like now you sound
reticent but let's be real we've had
many conversations about how satisfying
yeah actually one of the interesting
things we did an interview and they
talked David Serling said he actually
wasn't opposed to making snipers only
mode in the future which I would
actually love because I think some
people hate sniping because it's it's
effective but also obnoxious for other
players at times but feels so good which
is why I think a sniper only mode would
actually be fantastic should I help my
team or just go take B that's not the
team yep there I mean I would say one of
the most satisfying things to me in a
battlefield game
is getting one of those like like a 700
meter cat shot kilometer headshot
headship where you can't even see the
guy like like counter sniping like you
know the snipers there you know he's on
the hill you can see his muzzle blasts
and you just have to kind of just walk
the rounds and use your rangefinder
that's in the modern ones of course now
we'll say there are some really good
improvements to this game I have limited
amounts of ammo I only have 12 more four
more rounds in this tank classes so it
takes tanks can't just go indefinitely
and crime says or just let people create
custom games so we can come up with
crazy cool modes
you know that's legit that is totally
legit I you know I'm like me to go that
far
we just want the ability to make
playlists so that you don't end up
playing maps that you're not interested
in
I mean battlefield 3 and for head you
know you could find like pistol only
shotgun only sniper servers but I think
what you're talking about right is
having like the maps being sort of
almost like choosing maps in situations
that are like ideal for sight
not just having the option to use your
server settings rule out everything Opie
was there um because that's that creates
a situation where usually you know the
problem with those X or Y only servers
at least in my experience is how often
people would just go to those servers to
troll them and find like the most
obnoxious way of making it fun kind I
want to drive through this house just to
see what happens
nope next tank okay next thing we're
gonna drive through routes I look I'm
not good at sniping but for you guys I
will I'll try a little bit just so you
can get the flavor of it it's definitely
not my strong suit so fair warning
I have a sniper rifle it is on my person
all right gonna flat gun to the right
right provide some overwatch for the
move on a kind of wanna jump up on a
bridge
yep see a dead keep key finish that is a
dead man and you missed him all right
they were all up here okay oh there you
go
what where that bullet go so many
opportunities up there Aaron I don't oh
there you go hey the other thing I want
to try is spotting
because you can apparently spot now all
right let's change our mentality to I
can you can you got this I understand it
I can't spot so you look he's spotted
can you call in artillery though that's
uh yeah it's a good question is there is
there like a thing I missed that from
Bad Company 2 that was just this awesome
body shot respectable body shot whoo
there we go
all right they're all just kind of
flowing up for me and I'm steadily
running out of bullets cuz they just
keep spawning like rabbits yeah you're
good this is a really good spot person I
think it's no rabbits work they just
spawn all the time in real life
and so I'm not being effective mainly
because I'm almost out of bullets which
is the attrition system and also because
they keep spawning you're gonna have to
go through isn't that always the
question about how did they do the thing
that you can't do I feel like everybody
feels that way at some point in
battlefield somebody always does
something like you line up a guy from
range you get the perfect shot and you
you fire first and then you die I'm
gonna I'm gonna be honest though I am
that player you're the guy who kills if
I if I was like no I'm the I'm know like
flank this line playing from where you
shouldn't be or to where you shouldn't
be
I used to love how in bad company too
they wouldn't rule out of bounds the the
back of the map as the game moved
forward so if I was on a defending team
I would like as a sniper I would
camp out somewhere let the attackers
move all the way past me and then take
up a sniping position behind them I love
that as well my favorite things to do at
the risk of uh I was that guy at the
risk of an unpopular opinion I kind of
feel like battlefield should tone down
the player count I think if they're
gonna do small infantry 24 is actually
better it gives you more of an
opportunity to just do something as
opposed to 64 like 64 just feels like
too many on just too many for a good
match he's coming around isn't he kind
of want to turn this flat gun around can
I turn this around so so far I haven't
been able to remove trees which I you
used to you'll - I think in bad company
you could remove trees that were in your
line of sight
somebody Thome want to get towed use my
muse saying literally describing the
worst place though sorry but you know
battlefield is kind of about finding
your play style it doesn't require to
play a certain way
honestly it's sort of the point but I
hear you
this is kind of a it's a scummy way
alone it what am I getting accused of I
think he's referring to my let the
attackers past and harassed from behind
as hyper play style you know most of the
things that people complain about her
because they're effective tactics also
true-crime says have you heard anything
about competitive mode they did one for
battlefield one but it didn't go far
what are you interested in other also
federal players saying goodbye goodbye
hunter thank you for joining us you get
on a mounted weapon you get shot yeah
but I got kills first so it's worth it
I'm still recon general beauty 21 says
on metaclass if you tried pulling a
player out of harm's way so that was
supposed to be in the game let's try it
it might not be launched a lot of I feel
like a lot of features are not at launch
but will be coming by March this kind of
goes back to my argument where I just
feel like it's for small spaces like
this 64 is I'm sliding down 64 is too
many
I think they should actually probably
reduce these down to about 32 for these
small smaller objectives I think that's
okay
all right I'll try and chase drag a man
that man is down dry smoke Jeb the smoke
grenade I do not have the smoke grenade
I might have to unlock it Dustin Cordell
says this game has nothing on bf1942 but
I can be that truth do you think that
you know battlefield as a as a game
hasn't really progressed since its roots
or do you think some things have
improved over time cuz I I personally
think that it has gotten better you know
each iteration has had made has had some
improvements on gameplay or performance
that were definitely warranted like as
much as I love Bad Company 2 I do have
to admit that like battlefield 3 was an
overall upgrade to gameplay itself like
just the base mechanic
also you know we forget customization
came in much later right
alright let me try and drag a man
he was pre dead somebody killed him
already see like how do you make
progress when there's just so many
people running on the objective at any
given time oh that's the smoke this is
this is the smoke okay that makes more
sense now I thought it was a grenade
launcher but it turns out that that's
the smoke launcher oh so it's like bad
companies thing mm-hmm
where you can fire the smoke okay I
think I'm gonna be more useful now that
I know that smoke is absolutely vital to
pushing the objective okay have a have
an ammo snack or not
there's very ominous music going down
right now
it's probably what we're gonna get
because you are dudes it's not enough
dudes not enough to know dudes day two
is over
Joel's playing what do you think fall
it's only six so far he's saying he'd
play it before this summer saying player
count is what sets battlefield apart I
feel like that used to be true and then
the hero shooter came in and the hero
shooter just did such a good job of
making players fuel more valuable yeah
that's true but I also do agree that the
player account is part of battlefield
but if I'm honest I think that the
reason why the player account doesn't
always seem right is more a failure of
map design how you use how you use
channel exactly so these maps and
operations just channel a lot of people
into a very small space which is what I
think does not work and that actually
does work well with smaller player yeah
like 24 you're welcome Joel we are we
are reading through the chat and you
guys if there's you have any requests or
is anything you'd like me to do or see
again we actually just fired this up
this morning this is the first time
we've been playing here's my customized
character so we're down to test anything
you want us to test in these first
couple of matches I I'm gonna be honest
I'm not familiar with the maps and modes
just yet because we just started playing
so you guys are gonna learn with us and
we are
running out of time basically it's cool
it is 12:30 Pacific Standard Time we're
all gonna stand here and not a moat this
is my moat aha yeah I'm still
anti-reflux eight I have to admit it's
very not World War two you very not but
you know there was a World War one game
battlefield one that had all automatic
weapons which was not World War one so
yeah I don't think I anticipate saying I
can live I can live with it if the map
design and the objective placements are
good alright squad cluster sprue fire
everybody just ran through the fire and
caught on fire
have you played a single player yet I've
played three war stories I probably want
you to get on stream they're good like I
enjoyed them it's not it's not a draw
personally when it comes to battlefield
I don't play battlefield for
single-player but if you want to go
player you know this is the game this
year that has it uh let's see Joseph
Miller asked I'm not sure if y'all
addressed this but can you slide prone
like in the trailer or slide into from
yeah it's probably a lot easier to do on
console so it's like a weird double
click you got a you got a click and
press a whole bunch of stuffs
it's a double it's a double tap on
something
like I was pretty effectively laying
fire down that alleyway where if I have
my medic tanner Hartman says reflex
sights existed in World War two they
were called night our sights it's true
that a lot of modern optics are based on
things that were designed a lot earlier
than you think they were but I think the
general complaint is the prevalence of
those things you know you could even
still make the same case that a lot of
people said about World War one in
battlefield one about the automatic
weapons you can still say that about
World War two a lot of a lot of the
early fighting in World War two was
still bolt-action rifles the German army
was still horse back pain all right I'm
gonna try and drag just like a guy out
there
I don't think drag is an option US
Marines were using this be after the war
actually I'm using my smoke and now
they're behind us army got the garand
everywhere they're everywhere
general beauty 21 it doesn't have you
customize your weapons yet I did
customized one weapon I can show to you
just a second
it seems pretty robust a lot of
individual menus to do it but I'd be
happy before we hop off stream to show
you guys again now that's in terms of
cosmetics right what is what's available
in terms of G's I mean you had the
reflex I did it are there is there an
attachment unlock system way we've seen
oh you're just in all time
now I'm getting your Nate's band yay
this is like a series of real bad
funnels got to pick these guys up Aaron
yeah but this guy like Ranger boy here
dad like right there and he's trying to
kill me all right got him through it and
grenades fan shot through the car
there's a man right here and I don't
know if that oh okay well that helps
thank you to whoever just open that wall
up excuse like a map to open walls yeah
you know what it gets all close quarters
like this I'm just gonna say it you need
to lower the player count otherwise it
just turns into just getting shot from
everywhere I I kinda have to admit that
I like the chaos a little bit yeah I I
understand that it's frustrating but I
like at least that it's focused like
there's a your your focus on an
objective that's sort of the old rush
way like you know
how many people maybe in the chat can
remember how much fun it was especially
in bad company to to have only one crate
left to arm as an attacker and know that
everybody was pouring all of their
resources into that one objective of
course also lower player account so
maybe a bad example but tonight leave
now I can't lean all right Steven get a
play going you know I won't know if I
can do things like blow through this
wall there's an upstairs all right all
right all right let's uh let's go look
at an interior space nope nope okay
there's a ladder
all right go places and do a bell tower
I mean it becomes Cod no I don't think
it becomes Cod when there's an objective
that everybody is piling on - it becomes
more focused like battlefield is to me
is about the variety of the experience
not just one way or another you know I
think it's easy to say the call of duty
especially in its objective motor or
team deathmatch or actually just regular
multiplayer a lot of every to me even
though I like it every match is really
kind of the same with battlefield there
are there's open areas there's condensed
areas each part of the match is
different and the experience changes
over the course of the entire match yeah
this is how I work and so I like that
sometimes it's far away and sometimes
it's really yeah but uh like I said you
know we like to have a variety of
opinions I think everybody the GameSpot
office has their own opinions about
stuff I think that black ops for
corrected a lot of those problems
particularly with their objective modes
black ops for just has some of my
favorite objective mouth that bells can
I ring it ring a bell ring that Bell um
get another rocket lift if you're gonna
if you're gonna talk about small it
can't unsee the Bell now if you're gonna
talk about small objective-based stuff
like this where it's piling up then
black ops their mode is so good and you
know this is what you're doing right
mirror is another part of that - right
like when he gets when he gets super
condensed in in battlefield in a good
battlefield game you start opening up
routes you start opening up the walls
you start taking out the environment to
change house by me
but hey yeah black ops for you might be
surprised I was kind of a lapsed
battlefield player and I was heavily
drawn to black ops for this year because
of the objective based modes in the hero
shooter aspects of it I I will go to bat
for black ops 4 as the it's the first
black ops oh we're supposed to be
sitting that's what it is
we're supposed to be setting charges
it's rush style yeah black ops port is
the first Call of Duty game that I have
played in a very long time like since
modern warfare
general general Beauty 21's does debris
still kill you
yep I was totally wishing I was actually
I was killed by a Supply Drop uh earlier
hey I think it was a friendly Supply
Drop that killed me all the times that I
was killed by a piece of building and
hitting me in the head and I think
that'll kill three I think is where I
had it the most so this is uh this is
kind of rush light yeah it is
I can I can handle that I like it I like
it they're going through the poppies
yeah that is ripe for flanking
I will say that this optic has been way
better I don't know you can make a flank
you can try go for it nope oh this is
verboten you are not allowed to cross
that road what it but it don't you know
my memory might be weak but I feel like
Aaron and I company two in particular
made out of bounds a little bit more of
a map design and just an arbitrary
out-of-bounds area it might be totally
wrong about that sensei
let me give me bullets because I don't
have them so this is the attrition
system oh there was one behind us so
yeah like I have not this is the first
time I played these maps so I actually
don't know legitimately where to go
right now we just fired it up this
morning any any interesting questions
from the chat huh
ragdoll ragdoll is good man where was
that guy that I don't know if that was a
possible shot
Takeshi says very fast gameplay I miss
the old bf games I would like them to
slow it down and to be fair we haven't
played any conquest yet I think that's
where I'm gonna head next this is by
nature fast
given that everybody's basically honing
in on the same objectives I don't know
what these do yet I just oh those are
the artillery pieces they were supposed
to be destroying possibly fighting in on
these things
I mean anything's better than the number
Walker assault in the first from
Battlefront the first battlefront yeah
it was the first of the new battlefront
you had to like take points and they
need to make telephone calls to space
and then the telephone calls brought in
y-wings
and then the y-wings dropped an ion
shield and then you had to shoot the
thing at the right time
yeah that was a convoluted mode that was
very convoluted and not an altogether
bad idea it did not work very well I can
get an airplane maybe can I get a rear
seat yeah flip my controls before that's
gonna matter it says I miss modern
setting hi I hear you
we were talking about earlier World War
three scratches that itch a little bit
early access on Steam right now it's
very battlefield 3/4 II I you know I was
a little bit concerned when everybody
got super excited about both of World
War one battlefield because everybody
says they want World War 1 and World War
2 but everybody was so fatigued as hell
of those games ten years ago and I don't
I think maybe they want like a quick hit
but I don't think they wanted a full
franchise direction to go back
everything you know you know for older
gamers out there everything needs to be
World War two like all the right game
you couldn't get away from it you you
just could not get away from World War
two you and everybody was sick of it and
then everybody got a little sick of
Modern Warfare titles that Bell is still
there
um and then everybody said they were
sick of modern warfare titles so we're
back in World War two but in all honesty
I hope the feeling that World War two
fatigue subduing they're going to know
if you have rocketed the Bell yet I ran
that bill okay I can try is a waste of a
rocket let's do it that's your opinion
Omo that's a Mis man let me get more eat
more bullets
it's Alex for short says I think all
fans want Bad Company 3 III want to say
that is probably true right are there
are there battlefield fans who don't
want bad company 3 maybe you don't think
I can think of his people who just
didn't come into the franchise at that
point that makes sense ok there are
people who came into the franchise in
battlefield 4 and they may not they may
not want it because they just don't know
about it yeah like like battlefield 3 &
4 was where EA made such a huge push to
try and take as much Call of Duty market
share as possible it's when the inter
introduced team deathmatch and made sort
of like smaller more Cod friendly modes
in the game but to their credit they
were uniquely battlefield they weren't
they weren't like a copy you know david
goldfarb who was heading it up at that
time I think just made some incredible
maps that were rush Maps they're a
horseshoe-shaped or like kind of snake
shaped maps so they they were going for
that called redeem market share but they
distinctly made a battlefield game out
of it
all right maybe I can ring nope Ali says
gamespot you know is not acceptable for
Triple A game to be released finished
and we look up to you guys and other
reviewers to push back and criticize it
you know we did a sort of conversation
video about a week ago two weeks ago
about world war three versus battlefield
5 and part of that conversation
I think Erin you were saying that
looking at the battlefield roadmap and
what was forthcoming it does actually
seem like battlefield 5 relatively
speaking is something of an early access
game of its own it feels that way to me
honestly it feels like an early access
title I would make your purchasing
decision I know we'll do a full review I
don't want to speak for our reviewer
who's playing right now I will say that
we're not reviewing again I will say
this you can buy this game you can start
playing this game for $15 right now
through origin access which is a monthly
subscription and then just don't renew
your subscription and make a decision
for yourself
so you're basically paying an early
access price like World War 3 is $28 so
if you're on the fence about this pay 15
bucks and try it for a month and if you
don't like it cool like no no big deal
I think something to be said too and I
don't think it's no way it's a
concession to you know Electronic Arts
or some of these other game companies
but it's pretty common right now that
when a game launches it's really not
that finished early access is like yeah
like it's you know it's leaked into the
triple-a model and it's so much more
common now that a game is like really
kind of all that you want it to be
a year later or six months later and if
you're lucky that's the point where the
game is finally being discounted oh I
totally forgot about building that's
another thing um you know I think a lot
of people's acceptance of early access
titles is just based on how much they
liked the game and there's been a lot of
controversy around around this game so
maybe it has a bit higher of a threshold
for people to accept it as a as such um
but I I don't think it would be fair for
us to say you know we don't like a game
because it's unfinished simply because
of what Ryan said which is that early
access is now just like kind of a very
common model and I don't think and only
it's gonna go back there pros and cons
to it like the ability to develop a game
with your audience the price point can
definitely influenced your decision like
if you don't feel like something's a
full $60 game then you know straight up
don't pay don't buy it don't buy until
it's done when you perceive the game is
done then buy it that's what that's what
I've done for Co thieves actually so I
felt that way about CA thieves I made
the mistake with no man's sky of playing
no man's sky before it was done and I
regret it I actually wish I'd waited on
no man's sky and played it now I'm not
gonna play sort of what I did yeah I'm
not gonna play see if thieves until it's
a full game because I just because I
just know I'll get bored I know that
I'll just get bored and then I won't
come back when it's a full game so
a long story short like our
responsibility is to tell you what's in
it and you make the purchasing decision
yourself don't go out of bounds I don't
have any bullets right now this is the
attrition system so I did well and now I
kind of get what some of the youtubers
are talking about I'm sorry I did too
well and now I'm out of bullets
classic battlefield
thank ya triple kill nice
I did a ding nope check with gumbo once
enough we can build something oh yeah
now happily let me building show the
building mechanics III I will go with
awfully frantic for having building
mechanics it I will go back practical to
use them very often sorry I was like
interrupting that's a very good question
Ryan I think the building mechanics are
made are made for conquest in smaller
manages the building stuff is made for
for sorry larger Maps with larger spaces
between them i I do not think my honest
opinion is that they do not work when
there's this many people in one spot you
just don't have enough time and if you
do it they'll just get destroyed so
quickly that it's not a meaningful brick
but I would very much like to test it
out on conquest where there's larger
spaces in larger amounts of time right
like you take over an objective and
you've got a minute to actually do
something about it the person who asked
earlier about environmental stuff I got
killed by one of these before it landed
on my head and actually killed me
gamespot how our games but says damn if
only he had an LMG there yeah you would
have just mowed that whole squad you
know that first LMG doesn't have the big
if we have another 10 minutes I kind of
want to hop in the conquest really quick
just to see what it's like all right are
you guys feeling out there 10 minutes
does a Nazi symbol mean that much to you
yeah you know they did try and like take
over the world like legitimately so but
yeah like in fiction like if there's a
Nazi movie yeah it's probably accurate
and should be in a movie about Nazis I
did I think they're not okay don't quote
me on this but I think the Nazi symbol
was removed from this for it's been
removed from games because of the laws
in Germany which actually changed
recently I think when it's artistically
or thematically correct
they now allow Nazis
voules to be in fiction European movies
and content in Germany where appropriate
not if it's like uses hate speech or
something we're gonna pop in a conquest
real quick I really really really knows
want to see it yeah but yeah like I'm
alright I like obviously it's it's your
personal opinion but I'm okay with Nazi
symbols where it's historically accurate
or like thematically appropriate like
American History X or something like
that where they're trying to show how
disgusting that kind of nationalism is
okay conquest you know so there is not a
server browser there is I think most
people are in
conquest I think we had to do advanced
sorry play multiplayer advanced there we
go uh modes conquest
alright alright alright alright let's
see that's it
that's pretty hyping right now should we
see if it just puts us in one if we go
to random they're all full these are
German and English servers no I think
right now all we got is grand operations
there's only a couple of conquest
breakthrough we'd have to play in a we'd
have to play in a high-paying English or
German server but I kinda want to see it
maybe well let me try hitting that just
joined button and just see what happens
alright there's a halfway decent chance
this is just gonna kick us into a solo
match which is the thing that about
field one did a lot what are you gonna
do you pay me or that we will be getting
out of here okay we're gonna be playing
starting today through the weekend we'll
have a review for you hopefully early
next week
and yeah it's this is a it's an all it's
like an interesting one it feels like a
battlefield game that they're getting
out the door now you can honestly you
can pay fifteen bucks and play it
through origin access if you don't want
to pay full price but it feels like a
lot of the features are not going to be
fully there until March including
firestorm which is a tough window it's
gonna be competing with games like
anthem and Division two you know as
Ryan's pointed out Ryan and I both did a
piece on World War three and if you're
looking for more of a battlefield 3 for
experienced World War 3 is early access
for $28 and digging into that currently
I don't think it's gonna give us a match
alright well we might have to hop into
or cut you guys some gameplay of that
later on
too bad and let me go back to the server
browser real quick and just give it one
last one let's try all right give it the
old college try but we thank everybody
for joining us today to check out
battlefield 5 you know what instead of
waiting in a server browser for a while
let's close this dream out by somebody
had asked again for us to go to the
armory oh sure
so I just wanted to show you what that
looks like real quick so well you know
like I said we're not that far in so
these are those are the weapons you've
unlocked so far I got a distinguish
between company and armory
ok so company is your soldier that's
sick flute music going down armory is
your weapons filter Snyder once I shadow
this this is a purchasing section just
kick me into an area where I buy things
features so we got some veteran stuff
[Music]
alright menus just like classic
battlefield you just want to customize
my weapons please alright so here's some
no no shipments featured where are my
where my guns maybe
oh we were cured uh we were queued up
for conquest while that was doing it be
careful what you wish for so you still
have to quit out of a match to customize
your guns yes and I no no no we're not
doing this map they probably should just
hire a menu guy I think you and I have
covered battlefield for like a decade
now and I swear to god I think we've
been bitching about the menus for an
entire day I think that's true
bad company wasn't bad actually like
that company had the scrolling menus
which weren't too bad but good god man
I'm just trying to customize a rifle and
I'm like
trying to get rid of the menus there
under your company your company okay
thank you gaming with picks your company
so just go to the class presumably once
you get into customized there you go
okay there you go
so I did do web design in in college and
they're saying was more clicks as less
clicks meaning like that is the opposite
philosophy yeah you should have way
fewer clicks okay customize so I'll just
flip there real quick here's some
different sites I will say all right I
will say this this optic was way better
you can do your hand guard receiver
those are paid jobs or paint jobs what
about like attachments like what is your
so those you to change how the weapon
behavior those are in specializations so
the specializations are what impacts how
the weapon handles but you're locked
into it so like you have that that I
gotta be honest that kind of drives me
nuts so I like um I missed the I don't
want to say good old days
I missed the battlefield three and four
days where you could go to synth ik and
look at how each attachment would affect
the behavior of the weapon and you could
kit out all of your weapons based on how
you wanted them to behave so if I want
to start and even change that at any
time if you change your mind as long as
you had all the attachments unlocked
obviously which took forever
all right chat let's figure this out so
if I want to customize this weapon this
is paint so I think we have to replace
the weapon so it only says two of eight
so okay let's equip it and then so
that's customizing visually but what if
you want to specialize it
okay requires rank one so you have to
make a certain number of kills and then
you have to pay credits it looks like so
that's a weird way to put it
replace weapons so let's go back to our
first gun and look at our you know for
all of the criticism that battlefield
hardline gets let's be honest best
weapon unlock system battlefield has
ever had it was a money system you
earned money through playing matches and
you could unlock the weapons you wanted
unlock the attachments you wanted and go
after exactly what you wanted so this is
my favorite class so let's say we wanted
to start here right let's think this
through
so okay so there is an mg here in a
shotgun okay but that's locked so I
can't do it yet alright so this one has
progression so it looks like you gotta
use it and then so this is already
specialized okay so the first gun that
you're given is already sub-specialized
so it looks like you have to why is this
so confusing so it looks like you have
to replace the weapon with something
else and then start working through its
unlock tree so does that mean that we're
not getting any progression
it could mean we're not getting
progression on these starting weapons
maybe it's something just unlocks at a
certain point yeah so that's not as good
as weapon attachments I'm just gonna
call the ball on that one I would rather
just have good old-fashioned weapon
attachments yeah oh well um alright is
that it alright yeah unless anybody any
more burning questions we're gonna get
on playing a bunch more battlefield and
get on our review for next week i
everybody for joining us
uh not final thoughts but current
thoughts current thoughts we did a piece
which you should go check out last week
which was World War 3 verse battlefield
5 and my opinion based on the first
couple hours bath if I have not changed
I think if you're looking for the
battlefield 3 for experience you should
go check out World War 3 for $28 if
you're into World War 2 and sort of a
more polished experience with better
graphics and slightly better shooting
the classic dies experience then go I
would suggest you go pay $15 for origin
access which is a monthly subscription
and try it for the first month and if
you like it then you can stick with it
and that's totally fair most of this
game despite what despite what develop
dices like told me in interviews just my
personal feeling is that most of this
game is gonna be there by March it's
gonna slowly roll out until March when
and and by spring we should have
firestorm that's when I think the game
that was pitched at e3 is gonna be fully
in place and if you want to be along for
that ride then you know it's got your
class backfield shooting the explosions
are great sound design is fantastic as
ever destruction is is is pretty darn
good so far from what we've seen it
looks really good yeah yeah okay so
final conclusion from our just our first
stream is that it's got a little ways to
go if you want to get in on the ground
floor
check it out this week on Origin early
access I mean I think there's it's
there's enough there now that if you
just want to play battlefield you can
get in there and play battlefield yeah
but definitely seems like it's down the
road finished game it there's not a lot
of maps right now and there's two modes
of course this is the review build so
that's it's possible that's why those
other modes aren't here but one of those
modes is team deathmatch which I have
very strong opinions about shouldn't be
in battlefield of course because
battlefield is team deathmatch when you
get to the objective so yeah like I
can't I just can't quite form an opinion
yet it's it's too early and there's we
figuring it out we gotta figure out
what's here right what is the full
package right now and what
gonna be you know like another slightly
confusing thing now to draw this out too
much is a lot of it there's gonna be
like a decent amount of content within
the first month and within the first
month I think we're gonna get we're like
shooting range potentially rush large
tank battles so it's it's it's in a like
a weird spot where we're gonna have to
wait a couple weeks for that stuff I
will definitely not be able to form a
final opinion until I've played rush
yeah because I miss rush and that's my
favorite mode so until I get that I'm
gonna be awesome
other than that GameSpot is having a 72
hour charity livestream this weekend
just about everybody from gamespot is
going to be playing at some point over
the 72 hours from all of our different
offices from the u.s. from the UK and
australia it's for charity
it's to benefit children everybody
should show up definitely donate and
we'll see you on the next stream we'll
see you there thanks everybody
awesome I'm good
you